so i need to do something huge this time  i need to do something really important  because  uh i sat you know the shadow of all this  stuff all my life and  man just i mean the people know what  happened after that you know i i fought  against saskarov in mexico city it was a  draw a lot of people think i won that  fight yeah so i give you that you know  it's it's fine then i [ __ ] scared of  france for me got roybal figured it was  the first one murder is real man man  even when the first time i fell against  the smoke and my debut in the company  at that moment was the number nine  i think so you submitted them right i  mean yes my career in the company was  tough since the first the first time  as an underdog but now i'm on my way  stayed up every single night and hustled  every day  [Music]